we're the HSC seis waste or vce tens of
thousands of our best and brightest will
get completely frazzled trying to work
their way to a high score
[Applause]
remember there are plenty of successful
sexy people going around who reckon your
year 12 results aren't the be-all and
end-all
99.7 there's an eight are really it
doesn't matter you know I travelled
three months this year and no one asks
no one really cares just speaking
Finnish teas vce last year and now well
I've never heard of it you have to freak
out about your score you can always find
a path to the creative one in fact the
fully successful end sexy mark walberg
Carrie Stokes a Richard Branson Shannon
Bennett Simon Cowell and Steve Price
didn't even finish high school so what
does that tell you we should probably
talk to some women about it
take it away actor slash comedian Nikki
Britain it doesn't matter I haven't been
asked for years and years what I got the
only time I've ever revealed it to
people is a punchline in a joke nobody
hires you because of you're a star they
hire you because of what your interests
are what your personalities like I never
allowed the pressure of exams to get to
me which would probably explain why I
repeated you earlier there are even some
Australian schools officially giving
kids a permission slip to stop caring so
much about their final scores our
approach is quite diverse so you know we
we don't discourage the a2r of course
but we also understand and recognize
that success comes in many different
forms collaboration creativity critical
thinking if you are going to teach to
the test how is that going to best
prepare students for a world that's
rapidly changing look dudes point is if
you don't do as well as you'd hope in
year 12 for whatever reason just know
that life has a way of getting fully
lent if you work hard for it no matter
how appalling League you do in your
exams there's always the safety net of
show business
joining us now is mathematician and
Australia's favorite teacher Eddie whoo
now Eddie you're a maths genius you must
have absolutely nailed school oh look
that's a bit of a misconception even
though I can see why some people might
think that now that I work in a school
and it's my business but when I was at
school particularly in the subject area
I teach mathematics I was a real
struggler I was the person who's like
sir I'm still not getting it it's not
clicking can you explain it again
so that's struggle I think was something
I'm really attuned to seeing whenever I
have a my own students in class Eddy a
quick one six times 954 he's very good
advice would you give Eddy to parents
it's a very stressful time of the year
what sort of mood should there be at
home when this is all happening around
us look I also think even of my own
children who are still relatively young
they're just being there and being
normal with them like I took my kids to
the basketball on the weekend and we
just didn't talk about anything you know
we're trying to think about you know
which school you're gonna go to next
year and different issues about like
your final end of your exams or reports
and you know what it's just really nice
for kids to get a space with their
family where they don't have to think
about any of that just be human with
them and cultivate that relationship in
time don't talk to your kids about
anything but there'll be people watching
this who they'll do their best and then
the exam results will come out at the
end of your 12 and they'll be really
disappointed what advice do you have for
people in that situation and use that as
a motivator I think they're back to I
think it was Nelson Mandela who was
paraphrased to say you know I never fail
I only succeed or I learn and if you're
disappointed you know what use that as
you know fire in your belly to get going
and work harder but at the same time I
think it's really important to recognize
that not everything that matters can be
measured in an exam like that huge
plants of forming a relationship
communicating with people face-to-face a
lot of those things just aren't going to
come through a pen and paper test and
that's fine so keep things in
perspective and learn to move on it's
okay so there was advice but how did you
explain that to your parents because my
Egyptian father used to make me do
push-ups for every percentage that I
missed on a math test I got 95 said that
was 15 push-ups which is why I'm such a
tank
how did you manage those expectations
with you I don't believe this appearance
well while I didn't have an addition
father like yours I did have some pretty
tough my grandparents of my own and as
you can see I think maybe we met to the
same trainer like we've got the same
physique I'd say but I think that that
that management of expectations is
really tricky I remember my parents they
didn't want me to go into education that
was not what they saw for me in the
future so I think you've got to really
reckon with yourself like you've got to
ask that question really really
carefully what matters to you what's
going to matter long term and then you
know gauge your emotional you know
compass and all of the decisions you're
going to make around those choices gauge
them in terms of that long-term view I
think that's keeping that perspective is
what really helps so really what can you
bench what can i bench I literally I
don't even lift so much that I don't
even know how much I can't bench so they
finish comparing physics paddy thanks a
lot thanks guys
[Applause]
[Music]